jake is with us jake's in portland
oregon hi jake welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave and rachel thanks for taking my
call sure what's up hi
i have a question so this year i became
debt free i followed the baby steps and
i'm debt free and i've got approximately
70 000
in the bank with um that's including my
emergency fund
my issue is that my mother and my
older brother with mental disabilities
live in a
dilapidated house that's owned by my
grandpa
she's been living in it for 17 years
without paying any kind of rent and he
refuses to maintain it at all so it
hasn't had anything
done to it in 17 years it's currently
falling apart
it has mold in it it has holes in the
wall
i mean it's it's pretty bad i've been
running the numbers and i think it's
going to be about a hundred thousand
dollar remodel
so my question is should i buy this
house from my grandpa
and then put the money in out of my
savings into doing the remodel even
though i may not have enough right now
or do i say you know forget this house
and then move them out into a different
house because this is an unhealthy
situation and i'm not sure how to fix
this situation at the moment
what do you make of here i make about a
hundred and ten thousand
how old are you 32
you're an extraordinary young man
willing and able
to do this for your mom and your brother
with disabilities
well done um so
what i always think of is what is the
most efficient way
financially and time-wise to accomplish
the goal
and the goal is for your mother and
brother to have a place to live that's
not
mold infested and falling
okay so um
now there's two things you can do uh
what would i do if i were in your shoes
is your home paid for
i actually sold my home at the beginning
of the pandemic and now i'm renting
really cheap so i lowered my living
expenses by 75 percent by renting
so at some point again you will buy and
move on with your life in that part of
your world
are you single yes sir okay
all right um i would do a two-step
procedure if i were in your shoes
one is i would move them out into an
inexpensive rental immediately
and just pay for it
you make a ton of money and you have a
ton of money
in comparison to them and by the way a
few months of rent
is a lot less than buying a house for a
hundred thousand dollars
or remodeling a house for a hundred
thousand dollars you can rent a long
long time for a hundred grand
right yes sir okay so we don't do this
forever but my point is use of your cash
and burning of your cash if you rented
them a property
for two years what could you rent it for
uh yeah approximately around there it
would be about 1300 a month i believe
okay all right and so um
you know i'm probably going to cheat on
that and say let's let's try to they're
living in
a dump now let's try to make it a
thousand that's twelve thousand if you
did for two years that'd be twenty four
thousand dollars right
yes sir okay and that's a sizable
upgrade from where they are
during that two years save money
and buy an inexpensive property that is
way nicer than they're living in now
and pay cash for it and just let them
live there
okay and i think you could probably pull
that off in two years couldn't you
yes sir i think so and then you would
move on with you buying a house for you
later
do not move in with them and do not
combine your household
do not combine your households in order
to make this financial goal happen
okay that is not what i'm suggesting
okay
but uh where do they live uh they live
down in arkansas
where in arkansas uh northwest arkansas
around fayetteville
yeah okay so you can buy
you can uh 4x of their living situation
for uh 75 grand to 100 grand can't you
yes sir okay yeah i mean that's a palace
compared to where they're living
definitely yeah and just pay cash for it
and then all you gotta do is make sure
that the taxes are paid the insurance is
kept
up and um that your mom keeps the
utilities paid which she's probably
doing now right
um barely she's got a business that
wasn't
doing very well before the pandemic and
now it's just stuck a knife in it so
it's going to go out of business so she
has zero income at this point
yeah how old is she uh in her early 50s
time for her to have another income yes
sir and that's
uh something we talked about but if she
fights against it
yeah well sitting on your butt is not
going to work
this is an option so you can be generous
to a point but we're not going to be an
enabler either
so um you're a fine young man that's how
i would do it i would rent something
for uh probably less than a thousand now
that i've learned a little more
and uh yeah and then some you know good
area but it's an expensive area yeah
and so and good people uh but i i would
uh yeah rent something inexpensively for
a couple years pile up some cash pay
cash for it and then move on with your
financial goals
but also a part of that is she needs to
be able to maintain it
uh and she needs to be able to uh get
her career moving again she is in her
early 50s and this is a requirement of
the future of her life she has a 90
year life expectancy that's a long
time from 52